[Music]
any other question
yes in fact this is from kevin prudhomme
elder skeet can you provide some more
bible texts regarding the term bitter
herbs referring to oh yeah i saw that
bitter herb bitter herb first popsicles
in exodus 12
i think verse 7
where they were told they shall eat it
with unleavened bread roasted with fire
and with bitter herbs shall they eat it
so if god can't have you eating tobacco
and poisonous herbs bitter earth meat is
bigger to the taste not necessarily
unfit for food and the bitter herb would
remind you of the experiences they went
through and so bitter herbs
enters the bible as a component of the
passover meal
and the passover was the most
significant of the seventh annual feast
this is the crucifixion this is a
sacrifice of crisis so bitter earth is
not a reference to things we should not
eat it is an herb that is bitter yes but
it reminded the israelites of all that
they went through in the land of egypt
and also to get out
but tobacco is not a bitter herb in that
sense we're not to have anything to do
with tobacco not by taking it in or
selling it or buying it or manufacturing
it
nothing
if you work for the bucket factory or
company and you're the advertising
department get out
don't work for a system that promotes
damage to health which is another way of
saying sin
god will find you another position
because he's god
you